fois que jean lui qui est invité dans
l'émission je me suis permis de
ressortir deux ou trois saloperies le
concernant parce que vous avez fait du
théâtre un tous les deux pas du théâtre
dans le but de faire attendre et vous
allez voir de la performance théâtrale
et malheureusement pour vous ça a été
filmé on nous a envoyé les images la vhs
alors vous êtes au dessus on m'avait
jackpot soit un petit extrait est ce
niveau là on peut parler d'une
association de malfaiteurs quasiment je
vous laisse découvrir un premier sketch
que j'ai affectueusement nommé le bide
de la chaussette
regardez ce magnifique fait unique et
d'humour exemple numéro un j'ai pu tuer
moi j'aime bien la mi-août aux molière
oralair constat je me dis qu'on pourra
voir ça sur arte devrait pas décevoir
qui que ce soit mais c'est pas dans le
nouveau spectacle mais là la raison
c'est vrai voilà on aurait pu voir ça
sur arte bertrand vous aimez oui je
pense qu'on peut pas rire de tout même
charge encore mieux voici un autre
sketch du célèbre duo qui à mon avis va
devenir culé voilà après le ski et le
scrabble de pierre palmade et le blond
de gad sachez qu'il faudra désormais
compter avec le taxi jdid ioannina de
moine
attention certaines vannes peuvent
heurter la sensibilité des coûts drôle
agroscope
deuxième exemple taxi oui vous êtes
libre oui vive la liberté
c'est la chute
c'était c'est vrai c'était en public
sans plus je crois qu'il a déjà besoin
de nous ségécé bonne promo bon spectacle
alors elle est consternée lolo bonnart
lolo ça va ça va aller ça on vient leur
dire quoi
la vie va reprendre ses droits yassine
el condor pasa
c'est vraiment content s'en priver le
sketch des super héros préférés
attention ne tentait pas de reproduire
ses sketches et vous déjà pensé les
professionnels pour sauver la terre je
m'appelle sharks
je suis un débutant ma mère avait mangé
trop de poisson pané radioactifs et donc
je suis né en tant qu'homme requins je
suis clé dahmane
je peux jouer du piano au coin du feu et
apparemment là c'est pas que le contexte
joue pas de capter tout à leur solitude
trop élevé
balivernes avait arrêté en fait on avait
fait ça à l'époque où elle monte un
groupe on espérait remplacer les robins
des bois
très franchement après on se comprenait
pas pour qu'on n'ait pas été pris bah
maintenant je comprends on dit
franchement ils n'ont rien compris qu
lolo ça va mieux non non ça ça va passer
ça m'a pas encore faut que j'évacue
toute cette merde